Hello, everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel. And my name is Paul. Today.
We're going to look at the differences between two languages that many people
mistakenly think are the same Russian and Ukrainian.
The misconception that Russian and Ukrainian are the same might STEM from the
fact that Russian is widely spoken in Ukraine.
The numbers differ depending on the survey, but according to one, 2015 survey,
60% of Ukrainians consider Ukrainian their native language.
15% consider Russian to be their native language.
And 22% consider both to be their native languages.
These numbers do not include Crimea,
which has been annexed by Russia or parts of the Eastern provinces of Donetsk
and Luhansk, which are not currently under Ukrainian control.
Those areas have a Russian speaking majority.
It's also worth noting that most Ukrainian speakers can also speak Russian.
Even if it's as a second language,
some people may hear you and speaking Russian and think to themselves, wow,
Ukrainian is so similar to Russian,
but what they should say to themselves is wow.
Russian is so similar to Russian on top of that,
some people use a mixture of Ukrainian and Russian called pseudogenes and they
may not be consciously aware of which elements are Ukrainian and which are
Russian. This code mixing may also blur the lines between Ukrainian and Russian.
However,
despite the sometimes unclear delineation between the two languages standard,
Russian and standard Ukrainian are clearly distinct.
And the vernacular speech of most people is also clearly distinct.
Both languages developed from the old East Slavic language,
which comprised a set of mutually intelligible dialects spoken within the
Federation of reus, which later came to be referred to as key roofs.
These old East Slavic speakers are thought of as the ancestors of today's
Russians Ukrainians. And Belarusians when Kevin reus fell,
the Slavic tribes were divided into two separate States and the oldest Slavic
dialects in those separate States began to grow apart from each other and
undergo different influences.
Bribes to the East came under the rule of the grand Duchy of Moscow and their
dialects evolved into Russian standard Russian,
which is dominant today developed with more influence from old church Slavonic,
the old Slavic literary language, which differed from vernacular dialects.
Also under Peter, the great who aimed to turn Russia into a major Western power,
Russian adopted a significant amount of vocabulary from French and other
European languages tribes. The West came under the grand Duchy of Lithuania,
and then the Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth standard cranium was based on spoken
vernaculars,
specifically the Southeastern dialects and lacks much of the old church Slavonic
influence that Russian has Ukrainian also underwent a lot of Polish
influence due to geographic proximity and Polish political control with Polish
being a lingua franca for a period of time.
This is especially true in Western Ukrainian dialects.
Now let's cut to the chase and start looking at the languages themselves
vocabulary,
Russian and Ukrainian share about 62% lexical similarity.
I personally found this number surprisingly low Ukrainian has a higher lexical
similarity with Polish Slovak and Belarusians than it does with Russian,
especially with Belarusians even among very basic words. There are lots of.
Of differences.
The word for paper in Ukrainian and in Russian [inaudible].
I suspect the Ukrainian word was borrowed from Polish,
which in turn borrowed it from Germany.
The word for sugar Sahar.
Of these words are cognates that trace back to prodo, Indo European,
the Russian word traces back to all these Slavic.
While the Ukrainian word was borrowed from Polish, which boy.
I wrote it from German. The word for money dingy.
This Russian word is a borrowing from a Turkic language,
but Russian also has a cognate of the Ukrainian.
Word gushy, which refers.
To pennies or a small amount of money,
and is also the name of some older types of coins.
The word for morning rock ultra the word for bottle,
this word traces back to Polish. And then the German [inaudible].
This Russian word is also a lone word from Polish,
which in turn got it from French in Polish Bouteflika is a more general word.
Wild flashcards is more.
For hard liquor. Also.
The names of months are different in Russian.
The names of months came from Latin via old church Slavonic in Ukrainian.
The names of the months are original vernacular Slavic words, for example,
January in Russian.
And then Ukrainian,
she changed and February [inaudible] and so on.
With most languages, which are closely related.
There are lots of false friends in Russian and Ukrainian words that appear to
have the same meaning,
but actually don't this Ukrainian word means time chess.
This Russian word means our.
This means pumpkin out booths. And this means watermelon.
This means Sunday Magella and this means week sorority.
This means to scold in the imperfection of form so that each and this means to
boil in the perfective.
Form sheet. This.
Word means world Savitt. This means light.
This Russian word does have a secondary meaning of world,
but only in some fixed.
Expressions like.
This means to scold light. And this word means to.
Bark, orthography.
And pronunciation, both languages use varieties of the Cyrillic alphabet,
but there are a number of differences between the Russian variety and the
Ukrainian variety. First Ukrainian has this letter,
which represents the sound good,
but Russian doesn't have this letter in Russian GU is represented by this letter
in Ukrainian. This letter is normally pronounced as next.
Ukrainian has this, which represents the sound eat,
but Russian doesn't have this letter in Russian.
This letter represents the sound eat. Ukrainian has this letter,
which represents the sound yet in Russian. This letter represents the similar.
Sound yay. But in Ukrainian.
This letter represents the sound. And in Russian,
that sound is represented by this letter, a letter which isn't used in.
Ukrainian, Russian.
Has this letter, which represents the sound E a letter,
which Ukrainian doesn't have instead in Ukrainian,
this letter represents the equivalent sound. In addition to the sound,
for example, the words, meaning soap in Russian Manila and in Ukrainian.
Ukrainian.
Has this letter to represent the sound eat,
but Russian doesn't have this letter in Russian.
This sound is represented by a combination of two letters.
Russian has this letter to represent the sound you'll,
but Ukrainian doesn't use this letter.
Instead it uses a combination of two letters.
Russian has this special letter that doesn't represent a sound but indicates
that the previous consonant is in its hard to consonant form in a context where
you would expect the soft consonant form Ukrainian doesn't use this letter,
but instead uses an apostrophe after the continent.
So in Russian it's written like this object while in Ukrainian,
it's written like this grammar,
the concepts of grammar in Russian and Ukrainian are generally the same.
They both have three genders, masculine, feminine, and neuter.
They both have almost the same set of noun cases that apply to adjectives and
pronouns as well. They share the same major verb, conjugations and so on,
but the exact word forms are often different or at least not entirely the same.
Let's look at the different case forms for the now meaning head in both
languages.
These words are cognates in Russian Gullah and in Ukrainian,
these are both in the nominative singular form.
Notice that in the nominative singular, they are spelled exactly the same,
but sound fairly different. The first consonant is one that I mentioned before,
which normally sounds like good in Russian, but in Ukrainian.
In Russian, the.
Old vowel is frequently reduced to ah,
or Schwab when unstressed well in Ukrainian, it tends to not be reduced.
Now looking at the case forms.
One thing to notice is that the case endings have some different vowels,
some are different letters representing equivalent sounds. For example,
the Russian genitive singular and the Ukrainian genitive, singular
others represent different sounds. For example,
the Russian date of singular Gullah and the Ukrainian date of singular.
Another thing to notice is that while Ukrainian has a vocative case,
Russian does not,
the vocative form is the form you use when you are addressing or calling someone
or something. The old vocative form was lost from Russian,
except for a few specific words. For example, when addressing God,
it seems that it's being used less and less than spoken Ukrainian as well,
but it's still used by some. And as part of standard Ukrainian in Russian,
a new vocative form is apparently starting to develop in which the final vowel
is dropped. Usually from names and familial words. For example,
mama becomes mum,
but whether or not it's a genuine vocative case form is debated.
Another common difference is that in Russian, the copula bleach,
the word meaning to be is not used in the present tense.
This is often true in Ukrainian too, which has a lot of dialectal variation,
but in formal standard speech and in Western dialects closer to Poland,
the copula is commonly used. For example, let's look at the sentences,
meaning this is illegal in Russian.
At that music in Ukrainian,
it could be similar or it might have the copula like this
in Western Ukraine. It might be like, this
is similar to tall. Yes. In Polish.
Another difference is that you cranium has some additional verb conjugations
that Russian doesn't have in Ukrainian.
There's an additional way to express the imperfection of future.
That Russian doesn't have take the sentence, meaning they will be eating,
or they will eat in an imperfect of sense in Russian. I need Buddha.
And now when Ukrainian first with any equivalent structure
in both languages, there's the subject pronoun, the third person plural,
then the future conjugation of the verb,
meaning to be followed by the infinitive of the lexical verb,
the main verb that supplies the core meaning, but Ukrainian also has this form
rather than using the verb to be a suffix is attached to the infinitive
followed by the same future inflection that appeared on the verb,
meaning to be this alternate conjugation is called the imperfection of synthetic
future tense.
Ukrainian also has a PLU perfect conjugation that Russian doesn't have though.
Not everyone uses it in Ukrainian anymore. For example, here's a sentence.
Meaning I had been reading this book, but I forgot its content.
Yeah, [inaudible].
The blue perfect is formed with the past tense perfective form of the lexical
verb followed by the past tense of the verb. Meaning to be in Russian,
the sentence would be, yes.
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
In Russian.
The past tense perfective form of the verb is used rather than a special blue
perfect form.
This might be a good time to stop for a moment and examine some other
differences between these two sentences.
Before we saw that the words for this are different.
That was in the neuter nominative form.
Here they are both in the feminine accusative form. And again,
they take on slightly different forms. Next notice the words,
meaning book our cognate, but with different forms,
the Ukrainian word is in its diminutive form,
which is the everyday way to say book.
It can also be said with the same format in Russian,
but that would be more formal in Ukrainian in Russian.
There is also a diminutive form. Kishka,
it's less common than in Ukrainian and an even more informal word for book or
something like a booklet. Both words are in the accusative singular form here.
Notice that the words for, but are different. However,
it's worth noting that the primary meaning of the Ukrainian word is,
and this word is a more common word for, but,
and notice the cognate words,
meaning for God that takes somewhat different forms. Next,
these are the third person feminine, singular genitive, personal pronouns,
and these words are cognates. And finally we see the nouns, meaning content,
the Russian word [inaudible] consists of the verb,
meaning to contain plus Anya,
a suffix that forms abstract nouns from verbs. The Ukrainian word is a simple.
Now that isn't composed of these two parts.
Another difference is that Russian at least formal Russian makes use of active
participants to give extra information about a noun phrase while Ukrainian does
not. For example, the phrases,
meaning the woman's sitting on the chair first in Russian.
[Inaudible].
This phrase has an active participant, but in Ukrainian,
this meaning would be expressed using a relative clause.
[inaudible] this is like saying the woman that sits on the chair.
That's also how this meeting would be expressed in daily speech in Russian.
[Inaudible].
In the Russian sentence, the relative pronoun is cut throat, but in Ukrainian,
there are several possibilities, which is cognate with the Russian word.
Or.
As in the sentence above and as a side note, look at the different forms.
The word for woman takes in Russian it's Jane Sheena, while in Ukrainian,
it's the preposition meaning on is the same,
except for slightly different vowel quality.
And the words for chair are clearly related,
but take on different forms in the most basic form, the nominative singular,
the Russian word is stool and the Ukrainian word is
here. The are in the locomotive case though,
for Russian it's often referred to as the propositional case.
Now let's look at one final sentence and see what we find these sentences mean.
I can't go because I'll be working tomorrow in Russian.
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
And then Ukrainian [inaudible] Word for word,
both sentences. Are I negative?
Can go because tomorrow I will be to work.
Notice that the first two words,
meaning I then the negative are basically the same. Next. The words meaning can,
are cognitive, but have grown apart and are now pronounced differently.
Notably the second consonant next, the verbs meaning go are cognates.
There are both perfective infinitive,
both verbs contain a perfective prefix attached to the imperfect verb.
Next there's a compound conjunction meaning because in both languages and these
parts are cognates,
but the Russian compound contains an extra element in Ukrainian.
A different conjunction book can also be used. Next.
The words for tomorrow are basically the same after that.
We see the subject pronoun again,
but it isn't necessary and can be dropped because the subject is clear from the
conjugation of the verb. Both Russian and Ukrainian are pro drop languages.
Next, the imperfection of future tents is formed in the same way with the verb,
meaning to be as the auxiliary verb in the future tense followed by the
infinitive of the lexical verb, meaning to work,
but the lexical verbs themselves are different.
The Ukrainian word was borrowed from Polish.
Now remember that Ukrainian has the alternate way of saying something in the
imperfection of future. So this could also be,
as I'm sure you can see Russian and Ukrainian are very closely related languages
that share a lot of similarities, but they also have a lot of differences,
some of the minor and some of the major, lots of different vocabulary,
different pronunciation and different word forms that have arisen over time.
Make the two languages only partially mutually intelligible to people who don't
have much exposure to the other language.
But since most Ukrainian speakers also speak Russian or have extensive exposure
to it, asymmetric intelligibility is the norm. In other words,
Ukrainian speakers can often understand Russian while the Russian speaker
doesn't understand Ukrainian, especially Russian speakers from outside Ukraine.
The question of the day for speakers of Russian and Ukrainian,
how similar do you think the two languages are?
To what extent can you understand the other one and for other people,
how similar to Russian and Ukrainian seemed to you, if you enjoyed this video,
be sure to check out Lang focus on the various social media platforms like
Facebook, YouTube, Instagram, Twitter, and as always,
I want to give a very special thanks to my Patrion supporters,
especially my top tier Patrion supporters whose names are right here on the
screen, many special thanks to them and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice day.
Okay.